si santiago bastante polémica la jornada
terminó hubo el discurso del presidente
manuel macrón en el instituto de francia
y esa ofrenda florar aquí a mis espaldas
en los inválidos donde está la tumba de
napoleón y finalmente hay que decir que
el presidente macrón superó el desafío
recordemos que estaba muy preocupada a
la gente de como él iba a hablar de la
figura de napoleón sin mencionar los
puntos negros de lo que fue sus
sucesivos gobiernos y también su
trayectoria militar y lo consiguió él
condenó el ejercicio arbitrario y
solidario del poder que hizo a napoleón
el restablecimiento de la esclavitud
dijo fue una traición y no se ocupó de
las vidas humanas en referencia a los
millones de militares y también civiles
que murieron en sus campañas militares
pero luego también dijo que no iba a
ceder a quienes quieren borrar el pasado
porque no coincide con la idea que
tienen del presente y destacó también o
embellecido dijo en los puntos positivos
del hombre del emperador sobre todo su
voluntad política un hombre que
era una oda a lo posible dijo de una
persona que demostró que si uno quiere
uno puede cambiar el curso de la
historia y que llegó lejos la herencia
de la ilustración y obviamente que
estableció la estructura del estado
francés moderno que rige hasta hoy el
punto más importante ese código
napoleónico o el código civil y que
también han dios sobre todo forma a la
soberanía que emana de la revolución
francesa de la que él también recordemos
formó parte